men are better at all sports than women
are that's not sexist
that's biology like when I saw with the
mayor Pete like he was gonna come on
your program if I'd have a legitimate
conversation and in the same way I
treated everybody pee and and thence
people are like oh my god if you sit
down and talk to that guy you are
somehow like that you're cancelled to us
like it's crazy right I mean like I
would put the most right-wing person
like if whoever the Democrats nominate
for president I'd love to have them on
my fox sports radio show whoever the
Republicans a Donald Trump I'd love to
have him on when did we enter this
culture where somehow if you talk to
someone it means that you agree with
everything that they represent like I
said you know Malloy thought this crazy
way we framed things yeah so and II know
who got attacked by an island who I know
him and he was on the show last week and
he's a good decent guy yeah five foot
five soft-spoken little gay Vietnamese
guy and I only mentioned those
qualifiers right use there I did you
know ridiculous at anybody else against
themselves but it's like he's a decent
guy and the way that everyone is framing
it was either that the journalist yeah
check journalist we're all saying he's
either not a journalist they do right
he's not a journalist or he's a fascist
as if either one of those would excuse
violence no I would just say compare the
response to the woman who got killed in
Charlottesville yeah right by the by the
you know crazy deranged dude who I think
has got life in prison deservedly so
right and people were like oh my god
this is what happens in trumps America
totally innocent people get attacked for
their political beliefs and there was a
mass uproar you know it's still is
impacting things I think I've saw in
Charlottesville where they star no
longer celebrating Thomas Jefferson's
birthday as part of the file at fallout
from that they now have you know another
day that they've replaced it with or
whatever else again because people are
afraid I think to have a legitimate
argument ironically enough in a place
like Charlottesville which is founded on
the idea of intellectual freedom and the
cook the response to that attack on by
by a group that is I mean it's wild yet
or the Covington I mean the way that
they just you go narrative first and
then you
after yes where where are all the tweets
guys where all the tweets about what a
racist homophobic nation this one
doesn't work for you and I think part of
the problem is in a large sense you can
find evidence for whatever you want in
the world or in the country on a
day-to-day basis and what we've lost the
ability to do and I wrote about this a
lot in my book is comprehend probability
right like are there still racist in
this country certainly are there still
homophobes in this country certainly but
they represent particularly for acts of
violence a tiny tiny percentage of the
overall population yet in the same way
let's say there are 40,000 people a year
who die in car accidents if the media
decided to cover car accident deaths in
the same way that they cover police
shootings or in the same way that they
cover you know a mass shooting or
whatever else people would be terrified
to get in their car right I'd be like oh
my god we got another you know what's
40,000 divided by 365 I mean there are
hundreds if not thousands of people
dying on a week-to-week basis a
day-to-day basis and yet we kind of get
used to that right but also what is it
that they ultimately want to happen
yeah I don't know that's what I was
think about because it's like if I found
out that the guy who lives across street
me was a whole mouthful yeah right he
had an irrational fear of gape right
well as long as he didn't come to my
lawn and stand across my husband lob you
know yeah Molotov contrast yes your of
gabion your own home yes they're allowed
to do it like would it be would it be
worthy of my time or sensible for a for
a greater society for me to you know
picket designs
yes front him try to get him fryer
reserved you think at the end now I
accomplished all those things now yes
the move he lost his job he's destitute
his wife divorced him you think he's
gonna be like I kind of like a boy no I
mean I think that speaks to a larger
context a handshake is always more
powerful than a fist right ultimately
because and I think you've reached the
point way long ago beyond the point of
you know diminishing returns right where
if you looked it I wish that nobody was
racist I wish that nobody was homophobic
in this country but I think in trying to
drive it down to zero first of all you
end up in this strange world where you
have to define what is gay
homophobia and what is racism and
oftentimes you're coming around nowadays
to owner you know there is a there is a
more demand for racism in this country
than there is supply which is why the
Wall Street Journal had a big editorial
recently you mentioned Jossie Smollett
there is a huge desire to use this as an
example of the larger societal issue and
I think that's a failure of journalism
right if you think about it
journalism starts with story right and
the story will oftentimes be used to
illuminate a larger issue I'll give you
an example a lot of people are dying
from opioids in order to draw somebody
in to the opioid crisis it makes sense I
think to go talk about the impact on a
family in Ohio as a larger
representative for the tens of thousands
of people who might be dying or
afflicted by opioid addiction but that's
a massive issue in the country today
which has tangible results dead people
that otherwise wouldn't exist because of
the opioid crisis if you take something
that is not necessarily a major issue
today let's say that Jesse Smollett did
happen it was still a miniscule you know
number of people that was going to be
involved in this attack and it's not
necessarily representative of the larger
society yet that's the argument that
they try to make oh this is a stand-in
for something larger well no it's not it
doesn't happen very often at all it's
aberrant much like and this is the
argument I'm making my book a shark
attack right every shark attack gets
news right because ultimately we're all
terrified summer jaws season is going on
I'm sure when you go in the ocean at
some point when I do too o most
influential movie ever made is jaws
because I think I might get killed by
shark did that problem in pools
you know statistically it's totally
improbable yet every shark attack gets
covered so we think that it happens more
frequently than it does I feel like
we've lost you but if I could Hurley er
about like the nightly news the Walter
Cronkite's of the world there aren't
people saying you know this is this is a
reasonable reaction well bran for
instance said every day my son leaves
the house I worried that he might not
come back home and everybody was like oh
it's so brave of LeBron James to say
that more young black kids are getting
killed by bees wasps and hornets leaving
the house every day than by police if
LeBron had come out and said I
worry every day that when my kid leaves
the front door of his house he's gonna
get killed by a bee a wasp or Hornet
people have been like man what brah
needs to chill right like but it's more
likely or hit by a train right like it's
more likely and so some of this is just
the way we're wired like certain
people's brains are wired for that type
of hysteria you may have seen this video
when I was at University of New
Hampshire and all these kids yeah even
at me and yelling about yeah and then
this woman this middle-aged woman gets
up and she's screaming at me and she
goes these kids could be killed when
they walked out of here and I don't even
remember what I said to her but what I
was thinking was what are you what
planet-- oh yeah these are kids at the
University of New Hampshire right in the
middle of nowhere there's islands here
no one's getting killed and yet you're
an adult yelling these kids that they
should be fearful there if anyone should
have been fearful for their life at that
moment you yes but but that sort of
thing it just goes to a certain part of
the brain that then just gets bad well I
think politicians have become astute at
motivating base audiences by fear right
and I think certainly the left-wing has
become more more likely to do this but I
think historically the right wing has
done it as well right and the problem is
you need somebody this is where I think
Obama failed as a as a politician he is
a very logical guy whether you agree or
disagree with him I think he looks at
data and he makes arguments he should
have as some of this hysteria started
actually I think he could have made it a
tremendous impact if he had come out and
said look are there bad police yes look
I wish that there were no bad police in
this country some of them can't be
trusted but let's just walk through the
statistics you know the number one help
to entire inner-city America is police
officers right look here's the data on
murders as they pertain to over the last
30 or 40 years right this is a trend
line that's regularly going down here's
the number of police that we employ this
is a trend line that's going up
employing more police makes people safer
it doesn't mean they're gonna be
flawless they have guns on their hips
sometimes they make bad decisions when
they do they should be prosecuted in a
court of law like anybody else who makes
those decisions and I wonder on some
level whether Obama feels bad about the
hysteria because I think the problem we
had in 2016 was Hillary if you look at
the numbers of voters right Hillary
didn't get the same black voters that
Obama did and I think ultimately she ran
an identity politics of Laden campaign
because she thought if I make it seem
like it's awful for black people in this
country today and what Donald Trump will
do to them is gonna be awful then they
will turn up and vote for me which will
allow me to win the election and I think
in 2020 we're gonna see a reprisal of
that now the people in the Midwest were
smart enough who flipped from Obama and
Trump to see through that on some level
but this is an election that's gonna be
decided in Pennsylvania Michigan in Ohio
and Wisconsin I think those four states
and so whoever the Democrats nominate I
think they're gonna look at the black
turnout and say man if we got in the
same black turnout that Obama got we
would have won this election how do we
get it no matter who the nominee is in
2020 we're gonna try to sell fear to
that audience
you think the simple proof on that is
that we once had dinner with Candice
Owen yes with far-right racist yeah or
whatever the hell they call her now
but remember a couple months ago when
the reparations DIAC started bubbling up
and then Elizabeth Warren said you know
a commission and then the rest of them
started saying we're gonna get into
reparations yeah I texted Candice and I
said I think you've done it I think you
caused such a crack yeah in the
foundation foundation of that black
people have to be Democrats yes that
they literally now are saying what do we
got left
here's cold hard cash yeah that's all we
got left and the fact that they're
making that an issue shows that one
person I mean it's a through-line to
what we're talking about here that one
person that stakes out some brave
position yes that they really believe in
actually can cause immeasurable change
because I really do believe it is
directly related to what she has done
yeah well I think you can criticize her
and people get angry I defend her and
blah blah blah
well she's not perfect I'm not perfect
and all that stuff but I truly believe
it is because of what she caused yeah
look I think the foundation of identity
politics collapsing is maybe the most
important thing that could happen in our
country right because I think the idea
that you should be able to look at
somebody and guess who they're gonna
vote for is the foundation of our
politics today right and and certainly
fear if it's used to motivate a voter I
think is often bad now look you can
criticize the other side too right
nobody's perfect I think that
Republicans
look ins in general have over emphasized
the danger of terrorism right to make
people think that they're in more danger
than they are the reality isn't maybe
I'm gonna get shot as soon as I walk out
and that would certainly be an honor to
be my home but yeah gonna be your
homophobic neighbors who thinks I'm gay
but the reality is we have never been
safer right and I think about this a lot
as a parent because you know in my city
where I live Nashville Tennessee
I try to consciously let my kids take
risks like let them get on their bike
let them ride down the street we are so
so fused I think with fear as parents I
think that kind of translates through to
our kids who live in this incredibly
anxious world where they feel like
they're in danger and I'm like I you
know in the early 80s we were in much
more danger than our kids are today let
me climb for the house I'd be a hundred
feet in the air we come in for lunch I'm
like I'm gonna get down but I always got
that yeah I think about it now you know
like I rode the school bus in fourth and
fifth grade got home got off the school
bus walked all the way you know down the
street up to my house a totally empty
house unlocked the door went inside
stayed there for a couple of hours by
myself right I mean yeah and I was 10
right I mean and my I've got an 11 year
old now and if we go to the swimming
pool in our neighborhood across the
street my wife's like oh my god do you
think we can leave him here so I'm like
he's old he's gonna be in sixth grade
right like I mean but I think it's just
you know we have sort of built this
cocoon of protectiveness protectiveness
and that can be good but not when it's
motivated by fear and I think that bar
to this yeah Nashville so I performed
you might say yeah in the in the green
room bathroom over there is me at the
Ryman which yes credible Grand Ole Opry
was one of those member nights but what
is going on in Nashville that everybody
is so freaking happy I have never seen a
happier nicer maybe there's something
going on first of all look at the camera
or whichever camera don't move yeah yeah
we got enough of you you know where I'm
born and raised in Nashville I think the
culture of the place I've never seen a
group of every single person that I walk
by on the street
offered to bring me to their house for
dinner yeah me out to eat can I buy you
a drink yeah what can I do for you you
want to people you want can I buy you a
new jacket yeah yeah
it was unbelievable it's a super nice
community that I think I don't know what
exactly it is I think when you get to
southern element 2 I think the economy
has been booming so people do feel
really good about you know their overall
status in life 3 I think the
entertainment culture we kind of have a
lot of the la vibe of creativity and
just freedom and individual you know
sort of choices that that I think is so
important in life and but without a lot
of the negativity associated with it and
I don't know whether it's because
musicians don't have to be beautiful
like a lot of actors and actresses do
but it's a you know III really love it I
mean we don't want to move I mean I'm
born and raised I think it was a great
culture for me to grow up in and I think
it's an even better one for my kids I
need to be that you made a point of
looking at the camera everybody else is
out there saying like it's an awesome
place to move I'm like no we're full
right like you know how I feel like as a
parent kind of my kids are at perfect
ages they're 1184 and I would be you
know they're potty-trained they'd still
like to spend time with us like we we
can enjoy them as a family I'd be fine
hitting pause right now in my life and
having them hang out here for a little
while because I know you know my
father-in-law was telling me this he's
like you're in a good spot right now the
kids still have lots of problems but
they're almost all little problems as
your kids get older they have fewer
problems but they become a lot bigger
right and that makes sense right as you
think about it from a parent perspective
but the city of Nashville like you used
to be able to get everywhere in 10 or 15
minutes now the traffic is so many
people moved in yeah and that can bring
a lot of good things and it's been a
good audience growth a lot of
college-educated lots of bars
restaurants awesome entertainment scene
but we're full yeah you need to move to
another city it's funny because every
town that I visited lay out here
whenever I saw something really great
happening in that sound like Salt Lake
City I was like yeah people are
phenomenal yeah it's clean it's nice and
I did stand up there and I said
something about how great it is there
and literally people were coming up to
me after going don't tell anybody
oh yeah yes don't you guys are leaving
and ruining everything
it's funny when I said are they were
bigger than when I started my career
because I did local sports talk radio in
Nashville as my profile kind of grew I
would talk a lot about how awesome
Nashville was and this is you know over
the last 15 years and about two or three
years ago I just stopped talking about
how awesome the city is right because
I'm like
I think I've had too much of an
influence on some way like you know and
the people are just scrolling through
and they're thinking about where to move
I think it also helps by the way we got
no state income tax so if you're out in
California thirteen percent state income
tax let's say you make a million dollars
a year and you're an entertainer
that's a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars a year boom
that you have in your pocket in
Nashville that you didn't necessarily
have if you lived in California or here
it's it's I sometimes wonder why we
don't have more of our Fox Sports
studios out there cuz I'm you know doing
the show to finish the season here and
and you know it's it's great to be able
to do it on Nashville
alright let's back up yes to twenty
minutes ago I want to talk about some of
the gender stuff yeah elated sports
because you mentioned the women's soccer
team that's great they want okay
fantastic everybody's happy but yes
there are economic elements to this that
less people happen to watch the things
it's just reality it just is nobody
saying they're not worthy nobody saying
it shouldn't be on TV nobody saying they
shouldn't be able to play but this
constant then need where it became about
their victimhood yes they were winning
yes as you're winning but the whole idea
is a were you know we're not gonna
respect the flag and whatever they can
just they can do whatever they want but
then also just we don't get the TV time
that and it's like all these things like
this is such a such a misguided based
let's take let's take a step back I said
on my show and again this is something
that's reasonable that some people
consider to be controversial so you'll
enjoy this I said if you look at the
Women's World Cup
you can almost pick every winner solely
by determining which country has better
women's rights it's a fascinating way
just look at the bracket you look at
every Women's World Cup game that was
played almost every game without fail
the winner was the country that provides
more rights to women so it's fascinating
to think about we are as a country so
wealthy and so successful that we not
only embrace men's sports which many
countries do we also have so many
parents out there who will spend
thousands of dollars a year for their
women to be able to put their little
girls to be able to play soccer and grow
up potentially to be u.s. women's soccer
team member look at our girls that were
on the team the women that won the title
this year they used to be little girls
who grew up in pretty advantaged
backgrounds right because by and large
soccer in America
unlike soccer and the rest of the
world is a sport that elites play right
it's suburban sport especially for women
and so the argument that I made is if
anything Megan Rapinoe instead of saying
I'm not going to the effing white house
and she said [ __ ] I'm not going to
the [ __ ] white house which I think
sounds different
she should have in my opinion said you
know I have this opportunity as a
captain of the women's team to make that
argument that I just made if we can be a
shining light to the rest of the world
this is what happens when you give
little girls the freedom to pursue
things that interest them they grow up
into women who can dominate and so
there's a lot of talk about the women
versus the men right but the reason why
our men struggle in soccer is because
the rest of the world identifies great
male athletes and they develop them in
Iran last year was the first time they
let women watch soccer in their country
they require women to play in pants they
require women to wear the hijab where
you can just see their eyes on the
football the on the soccer field another
thing about that is it a surprise that
us women would dominate a country that
doesn't let women wear shorts or attend
soccer matches is it a surprise that we
would dominate Saudi Arabia where they
just started letting women drive cars
you know so our women's success to me is
actually a reflection of the ideals that
they should be trying to shed and shine
a bright light on for the rest of the
world having said that the rest of the
world doesn't care about women's soccer
like the United States does so pure
economics when you look at this and
again this is pure rational economics
the men's world cup produced most
recently the most recent numbers I saw
four billion dollars of revenue right be
the Women's World Cup and I think it was
the most recent by 2015 produced 73
million in revenue associated with it
now that's continuing to grow but the
men in America actually made a smaller
percentage of the FIFA revenue I think
it was 9% then the women did they got
13% so take a step back from everybody I
think in general is in favor of equality
right I mean there are very few people
who are like oh I think because of your
sex you should have less rights than
someone else again tiny tiny percentage
so to me when you look at this it's just
a function of a kind
I wish I made the money that Howard
Stern makes right we do the same thing
we talk on the radio every morning why
do I make less money than he does
because my audience is smaller and the
reason why the u.s. women and the
revenue that my audience produces is
lower right it's basic economics so I
understand the argument of oh the US
women deserve more certainly I hope they
get as much as they possibly can on a
capitalist I want every individual to
make as much money as they can but the
money's not there right and so the
reason why the money's not there is
because the world not the United States
the world doesn't value women's soccer
as much as they do men's soccer you
think Trump every time Rapinoe or one of
these athletes says they're not gonna go
to the White House or [ __ ] the White
House or whatever yeah you think he's
just like hallelujah hallelujah this is
just gonna make me more popular because
to me it's the ultimate virtue signal
yeah I not instead of saying that why
not you honored your country you you
want yeah for your country why not show
up the white US and then do what an
adult might do which when he walks by
and shakes all your hands say mr.
president I'd love to have five minutes
with you and warm the meeting which he's
shown that he's willing to do like this
is what's so crazy this about me and
IIIi don't know about you but this is
what really bothers me in general about
the discussion about the White House
visit I would go to the White House if I
were invited by Bill Clinton Barack
Obama George W Bush George Bush Donald
Trump the idea that that is somehow an
endorsement of whoever is president is
crazy to me to me it's just a respect
for the office itself and the location
and that's why when Megan Rapinoe said
the [ __ ] White House it's like the
White House is a symbol that represents
everything that's good and great about
America including the rights that
allowed you to become such a dominant
women's soccer player to begin with and
by the way and you know this better than
me I believe on election to enter the
White House for the first term Trump is
the most gay LGBT friendly president
ever literally well first off he was
basically Pro gay marriage yes remember
Barack Obama again was not ready 2008 he
was on stage with a freaking gay pride
flag oh yes before the election Peter
Thiel at the at the spoke of the are
see ya proud gay man gets a standing
ovation you don't even knew what to do
so yeah it's all it's all just bananas
and so that is what is so problematic
and disappointing to me in many respects
is what does she actually disagree with
and that's the question where I think
the sports media often does not go the
next level they cover the surface a
level it's virtue signaling right okay
the next question for Megan Rapinoe is
okay what do you specifically disagree
with Donald Trump that he has done not
just that like a mean tweet that he sent
or something like like a tangible
decision and why would you not take the
opportunity to sit with the most
powerful man in the world
and talk to about it because if anything
Trump has proven to actually listen to
some of these arguments right like is
the catch-22 though for not for you but
yeah you can do what you want and you
can control the content you're creating
but for ESPN I get it they can do it at
sort of the basic level but then the
more they were to do of that it's the
more that a guy like me who I'm not I
don't really care about soccer yeah that
I was telling you right before we
started I think that I just now flick
through like I see yeah and it's so I
used to you know even five years ago I
would always stop on yeah and what's
going on and now it's just like I know
that whatever is on right now I could
not care less about I think what would
happen is the athletes would get exposed
by and large cuz you would find out
right that what you would find out is
there's no depth to their actual
political opinions because they're doing
other things full-time right like I
think if LeBron James who is obviously
super loke right now because I think he
gets positive feedback on social media
and everything else if you set him down
and said okay LeBron like you called the
president a bum explain why specifically
you think the president is a bum and
what you would change differently if you
were in the White House you would
realize wait a minute like he would just
him in Hall and he wouldn't have any
answers like you or I or any number of
people and maybe that athlete does have
some depth to them and that's why I've
always offered you know like I offered
Colin Kaepernick I offered LeBron James
I offer a Megan Rapinoe like come on my
show and actually make your arguments
that you believe you have this platform
to make we never see that happen right
we hear people say oh I've got to use my
platform well how are you using your
platform to advocate
like an actual change or some sort of
detail I never seen that actually happen
it's interesting your point about how
Trump would be happy to take these
meetings yeah because you're right he
does take these meeting all the time
especially with famous people when it's
good television ops right like Trump
sitting with Megan Rapinoe on the other
side of the desk in the Oval Office he
bled all the me [ __ ] with Kanye and
Kim Kardashian right like Trump is a
very cognizant of the amount of
attention that he can get and the more
famous a person he meets with the more
attention he's gonna get particularly in
the world of sports
whether it's Jim Brown whether it's he
just announced that the logo Jerry West
he's bringing in Tiger Woods Trump's a
sports fan right and I think he enjoys
Tom Brady obviously that all of the talk
about the Brady and Belichick
relationship and everything else and so
I think he enjoys being able to interact
with them as president and yeah I think
he would always have that meeting if you
wanted to have that meeting do you get
any feedback from women in the sports
broadcasting yeah that are sick of the
woke 'no swen it comes to all that years
though yeah that's got that to me is the
most obvious one like we can argue about
some of the the racial stuff
yeah and numbers and things like that
but this one now where we're seeing you
know trans wrestlers beating the crap
out of you know genetically female women
and yeah like now the feminists are well
or that yeah I think that are we doing
yeah I think that so you talked about
how do you blow it up I think you have
to follow the logical collapse of the
argument right and to me choosing your
gender is it's wild to me that we're
okay with choosing your gender but
choosing your race is wildly offensive
right like so Rachel Dolezal is a like
is like a social pariah yeah but if
Rachel Dolezal was a woman who decided
to be a man we would all have to respect
that decision and my thing is it seems
easier to choose to align yourself with
a racial group than it does to change
your gender right right but the next
step there is a world soul man yeah yeah
can you imagine that coming out today
that would be amazed
but to me the next step that you take
that is that is that it's fascinating
here is Caitlyn Jenner is a great
example
ESPN gives Caitlyn Jenner and espy what
would have happened if in the 1970s when
Caitlyn Jenner is dominating Bruce
Jenner is dominating in the Olympics he
had then decided I'm going to become a
woman and I'm gonna come back and I'm
gonna you know compete against all the
women he would have dominated even more
right like this is the greatest athlete
in the world as a man if he flips over
and becomes a woman he's gonna dominate
even more so this idea that you can
choose your gender and that you should
then be allowed to compete as that
gender it's like they made a joke movie
about this do you remember like Juwanna
Mann but that is going to that's the
logical fallacy of the Arg cannot wait
till some 42 year old wash up washed-up
MBA guy who played like seven season
yeah scored three points a game becomes
the best player in the WNBA WNBA and you
guys are gonna have to take it yeah I
mean and I think that's honestly what
you need to have happen in order for the
logical fallacy of the argument to fall
apart right like and I think that's
ultimately what spells the end of locum
in the world of sports is what you're
just talking about there gonna be a lot
of dads and moms who have watched their
daughters train their entire life to be
able to win the sprint state
championship and then there suddenly is
a 17 year old who is a male that has
decided to identify as female and wins
the competition by 20 yards right
because this is men are better athletes
than women like I've got people right
now my twitter mentions talking about
the u.s. women in the u.s. men debate
and they're like oh if the US women
played the men they'd win and I'm like
you the US women lost to a 15 and under
boys all-star team from Dallas right
like men are better at all sports than
women are that's not sexist that's
biology right so therefore men who are
bigger stronger and faster than women
who suddenly decide to identify as women
are going to be better and even
they get all the complicated hormones
stuff like you're still built physically
in a way that most women are not right
like you're still you got all the height
advantages of testosterone all the
shoulder you know strength everything
else it's it's it's not it's not
offensive to say that yeah and a woman
dunks in the WNBA which is only happened
a handful of times yeah it's like a
miracle
yes it's everywhere I'm pretty sure John
Stockton dumped once well it was like
this says again in my book Republicans
buy sneakers too John McEnroe got
criticized for saying Serena Williams be
like the 700th best men's player in the
world I talked to a bunch of men's
tennis players pros and they're like she
couldn't make a men's college team
tennis team doesn't mean she's not an
outstanding women's tennis player yeah
but her talent doesn't translate into
the arena with men and that doesn't mean
that women are inferior to men in life
right it means that athletically men are
superior to women well you saw the way
they were going after Martina
Navratilova oh yeah when she wrote that
piece and that speaks to I think the
danger of actually interjecting yourself
into the conversation because Martina
Navratilova could have just said out of
it I think she wrote an op-ed piece in a
British newspaper yeah I remember there
was one season right maybe the first or
second season in the WNBA you remember
Cynthia Cooper who got on the Houston
Comets and she was like running circles
around everything she had great handle
she had all these sick moves and I
remember watching her and I was like
could this girl possibly make it in the
a man in my mind I thought that maybe
she could yeah but that's just crazy
Ludacris it's just crazy it's it's like
the argument and this goes into title
nine that I've always found would be
fascinating from a legal perspective you
talk about extending the logical the
logical fallacy of the argument football
is not a men's sport like if you really
think about it every scholarship that
you get in college to play football is
open to women like softball is a women's
sport baseball is a men's sport men's
basketball men's sport men's you know
basketball
I mean women's basketball women's but
they're right they're defined by their
gender football is open to everyone if
Tom if Bill Belichick could find a you
know five foot four woman who could be
the take over or six foot four woman or
whatever it is for Tom Brady he would
sign that person to play in the NFL and
so would every
college coach those women don't exist so
is that the sickest twist to this whole
thing that sports really because of
rules yes he's the great equalizer whoa
you never played the ultimate
meritocracy you know I think I maybe
told you this last time you were here
but Sue Bird went to the same high
school yeah she was younger than me but
every now and again she would come out
to the courts where I was praying and
she'd run circles around everybody yeah
it's awesome yeah I have no problem
saying that she was freaking awesome
yes and it's like that doesn't mean
she's gonna go to the NBA right but we
can acknowledge that within the skill
set playing against all of us yes yes
you freaking killed us to me it's like
looking at the the scatterplot or the
bell curve right like most people are
somewhere in the range of the top right
and then there's outliers if you put
male and female athletic ability on that
same chart it doesn't mean that some
women are not substantially better even
than most men when it comes to
athleticism but when you look at the
extremes which are the people who end up
making a living the men athletically are
on a totally different stratosphere than
the most athletic women
so when you say Sue Bird is a great
example Sue Bird can be a lot better
than most men at basketball and nowhere
near the extreme of the most talented
men's basketball players all right let's
we only got a couple minutes left so
let's just hit a couple things so
there's also been a little through line
here that sort of as people like you are
doing their own thing out of the
institutions and as the institutions are
crumbling I've come to the belief that
sort of the platform's that all of this
is going to crumble that none of these
things are sustainable and it'll be on
creators yes and innovators to figure
out how to reach their communities do
you kind of view the future of the
internet that way because I'm also in
the middle of that game right now which
is just what is all of this going to
become yeah I think a lot about that
because what am i Altima T in the
business of words right I produce and
that's why the money that I've made I've
tended to roll into buildings right
because everything that I do is so
ephemeral but I think we're in an era
when and I don't know what it's gonna be
I think it's gonna happen soon you will
get into your car which you may not be
driving at all but would be transporting
you somewhere and you will hopefully say
play me the most recent clay Travis
right and boom it's ready to go now
podcasts kind of have that but I think
that all audio is going to converge
right I think radio I think podcast I
think you know shows like this which can
exist in both audio and video format
everything converges and it becomes an
opportunity to distribute your content
in a way where there's almost no
top-down right everything sort of
becomes bottom-up and what can
eventually happen is bottom-up can
become massive and I think the ability
of companies to create stars is going to
be diminished and almost everything is
going to be rising from a bottom up and
then big companies will say oh I see
this person they're successful and
they'll try to attach to them but I
think all the time about for instance on
television I think you'll come in and
you'll sit down and you will click on
the latest app uploads from you know
maybe it'll be people like you and me
all coming together and like we'll have
our own brand and it'll be under this
brand umbrella right you can go kind of
check because you know what people like
you they might like me and you kind of
get a finiti that way everything is so
competitive and to me Reed Hastings has
said it so brilliantly our competitions
not HBO it's sleep and I think we're all
competing against sleep I think there's
so many you know I was talking about
this with a buddy the other day
Sports used to be in the summer I'd sit
around and watch the Braves on TBS I
watched the the Cubs on WGN whatever
other game because everything else was a
rerun on television in the summer right
nowadays I think baseball struggles
because stranger things threes coming
out right like my kids watching stranger
things right now my oldest is my two
younger be terrified I think if they got
to watch it so we're all competing
everywhere simultaneously I think the
amount of audience will diminish but I
think the intensity of that audience
will grow such that people really really
love the things that they love yeah it's
interesting how when you're in these
things even though we're in sort of
different worlds that I have a lot of
overlap that you start thinking about
the same oh yeah because I'd be getting
offers left and right and what I keep
coming back to is for the first time now
just because of the craziness with
YouTube and everything else I'll
consider distribution offers well yes
just I just want my stuff to get out
there I don't care whether you hopped in
your automatic car and you can just say
play Rupert or it's some other way but
that appeals to me rather than
the reverse of the top-down thing yeah I
don't want to be associated with these
big things that will ultimately one day
come and get me so it's it's interesting
how we all sort of end up hovering
around the same ideas yeah and look I
mean the reason why I love doing your
show is I do think there's
cross-pollination right I thought people
like we're gonna have gonna have you on
my podcast I think some people will hear
you on my show and they'll be like I
never knew that guy existed oh I like
him right and so I think it's it's gonna
be incumbent upon creators to find other
creators that they like and sort of
allow those two audiences to intermingle
in some way to create bigger audiences
for people of like minds let's just wrap
with one other thing we talked about it
right before we started just the way
money is completely out of community I
kept asking who's the guy that just
signed that crazy deal so Danny Green
and this guy he's won a couple
championships any point shooter decent
player I don't think he's ever maybe
made an Oscars game of thirty million
dollars 30 million 40 million II that
these numbers are getting so out of
control that at some point people are
gonna go to these game I mean I haven't
been to I didn't go to one and be a game
season for the first time in my life
right I was just more because I was busy
but it's like at some point these things
will just price themselves out and
everyone's just gonna be like I'm not
buying these $80 jerseys anymore I'm not
buying $12 soda yeah I think what
athletes are gonna have to recognize is
who pays their salary and I think this
is I think an important lesson for
anybody employed by anyone who pays your
salary where does the money come from
right following that thread to knowing
how you get paid I think a lot of
athletes have become comfortable
alienating the fan bases that define
their paychecks because they don't see
that direct connection right because the
television contracts are signed for ten
years because their contracts are
guaranteed for multiple years but
ultimately it's the fan pulling money
out of his or her pocket that is
justifying what you are allowed to make
and I think whether it's Colin
Kaepernick whether it's LeBron James
alienating fans Megan Rapinoe for any
reason is just bad business right and
that's kind of the essence of my
argument is that Michael Jordan had it
right when he was asked how come you
don't get intensely political because
Republicans buy sneakers too he's not in
the business of meeting for everybody to
know what he thinks about politics from
one day to the next and I
think as as athletes are trying to turn
into repositories for political ideas
good you know left-right and different
whatever they are it's bad for their
brands and it's bad for the league's
overall all right follow clay Travis's
brand at play Travis on the Twitter
[Music]